here's a story from the post-millennial
RFK Jr tells Joe Rogan he is concerned
the CIA might assassinate him you know
this is crazy they say during the
interview with Joe Rogan Kennedy said
his uncle John F Kennedy quote was at
war with his military and intelligence
apparatus after he said he wanted to
take the CIA and shatter it into a
thousand pieces and also scatter into
the wind
he uh who he said had lied to get him to
invade Cuba Kennedy discussed his
uncle's refusal to send soldiers into
Vietnam at the military-industrial
complex's request he noted that JFK was
killed a month after ordering all troops
out of Vietnam when he determined that
75 Americans who were killed in the
country were too many quote he believed
that the view of Americans abroad should
not be you know a soldier with a gun it
should be a Peace Corps volunteer
building you know Wells Kennedy said it
should be usaid helping poor people and
it should be the be Alliance for
Progress building middle class and
that's what he did and he started the
Kennedy milk program do you know give
nutrition to the poor kids all over the
world as a result of that in Africa
today there's more statues to John
Kennedy more boulevards named after uh
named after more Hospital schools
universities Avenues and all the major
cities named after him than any other
president the podcast host aftem
what do you think happens when you get
an office like if you're talking about
your uncle who was assassinated and you
believe the intelligence agencies were
part of that what happens to you and he
replies I gotta be careful and I'm aware
of that and I you know I'm aware of that
of that danger Kennedy responded I don't
live in fear of it you know at all but
I'm not stupid about it and I take
precautions
did you think
at any point in your lives we get to the
point where we would be sitting on a
show like this and be like two very
prominent individuals one who's pulling
highly for the next presidential
election would outright say that the
intelligence agencies killed a sitting
President also his uncle
you know like uh 10 years ago I would
have said this is an impossibility and
the sad reality is that right now I'm
sitting here and it's almost like
there's no no response to it whatsoever
it's almost become unexpected kind of
thing where the most extreme possible
thing plays out I know people who were
completely shocked he even entered the
race for this reason they're like
there's no way there's too much of a
Target on him uh which I also find to be
kind of interesting like he says he's
interested in it he he's aware of it
he's gonna uh he he's not gonna live in
fear but he is aware that coming out
with these accusations and then seeking
the presidency is uh maybe not in his
best in his in his personal interest
yeah it definitely puts us was it wasn't
there movement on the Warren Commission
like 10 years ago too there was like a
an unveiling of documents around this
time 10 years ago or something they keep
doing stuff like that like every so
often remember we were talking about
last time like every time Joe Biden
screws something up you just release a
couple of documents let's step out it'll
be great also you should worry too
because there's a lot of streets named
after Martin Luther King and a lot of
people believe that the government had a
hand in that as well yep a lot of people
I don't think they do it so much anymore
I'm actually not super worried about RFK
Jr getting assassinated I mean I think
it's a possibility I think uh the powers
that be have it within them
it might be something like uh you're
going for a burger and you get mugged
yeah oh too bad but typically I think
they go with character assassination
because I want to make sure your message
can't persist well it's far more
effective I mean if you want to take
someone out nowadays you take them out
by just erasing the person they are just
creating an entire villain around them
and they're more effective at that I
mean you don't want to have a martyr
yeah I mean remember that the mainstream
media will not acknowledge that he's a
serious Contender for the Democratic
nomination they refer to him
consistently as a fringe candidate and
then they immediately bring up his
theoretical stance as an anti-vaxxer
right like they use that to to tear him
down as much as possible in doing so
they don't realize that he has broad
appeal they will not acknowledge that he
actually has an interesting shot he
plays an interesting role in politics
right now because I think they are
afraid of him the best thing for uh
America's left to do right now is try to
get him to stop talking as fast as
possible you know what's super
interesting about the vaccine thing is
they don't realize how many people in
their own party are actually on board
with his message well his his polling is
I think he's rivaling is he is he I
think he's beating Joe Biden in
favorability that is I think the things
that he's saying are lighting up regular
people who don't like Joe Biden don't
like what the Democratic party's become
and they don't like Donald Trump Yep
they're they're I think there are a lot
of people who voted for Trump
I'm sorry voted uh voted for Biden
against Trump I think you know that was
why I really believe no one voted for
Biden they voted against Trump exactly
and now that RFK comes along they're
like don't know don't care he's a
Kennedy sure fund whatever you uh Yugo
says that RFK has higher favorability
than any other presidential candidate
running in 2024. 39 it is true that
there is almost no appeal for Joe Biden
because I like like we cover pop culture
and I've seen several celebrities who
are just like James Vander Beek was like
we have to at least have the discussion
that other candidates are a possibility
uh
um Arnie uh the governator recently was
saying that he wishes he could run uh
given that he's not a naturalized
American when he wasn't born in America
because he says that there's there's
nobody right now that can unite everyone
which is tacitly admitting that they're
not uniting anyone right now and these
are mainstream celebrities who would
normally fall in line for leftist or
democrat policies I don't think uniting
everyone's a realistic goal right yeah
it's not everyone to compromise I mean
this guy became the governor as a
republican in California so anything's
possible but it used to be a thing
though I mean there used to be a
democratic there used to be a republican
stronger actually in Orange County right
like that was a different time we are so
used to seeing uh America through a
modern lens that we forget I mean we're
in West Virginia West Virginia used to
vote consistently Democratic the parties
shift the the same way that the party
shift in ideology and they have Drifters
left the voters shift too to stick with
their core beliefs
yeah I believe at this point that kind
of unity is just impossible and I don't
think anyone deep down believes it what
if
we get this magical unicorn scenario
RFK runs in the primary
Biden wins
RFK says I'm not leaving
Trump wins and then Trump says RFK Jr
run with me let's let's let's unite what
we're working on together for the
American people what happens if it comes
Trump RFK Jr single ticket a trump
Kennedy ticket that is a powerful I mean
I've seen a lot of uh uh speculation
that Hill RFK Jr will run as a third
party which will basically have a Ross
Perot effect and Hemorrhage uh voters
away from Joe Biden I mean RFK is a a
real problem for the Democrats and you
know he just has to be not enough of a
threat to the Republicans to Hemorrhage
moderate voters who lean in both
directions yeah if he runs as an
independent he's definitely going to
cause a Major Impact for the Democratic
party it's it's he's gonna
unintentionally or intentionally
sabotage them completely yeah I think
potential debates are somewhat useless
right like we do get some fun sound
bites when Donald Trump's on stage but
they don't really tell us anything uh
but I would love to see Kennedy debate
Trump or Biden or literally anyone
because I think he is sort of this this
breath of fresh air I think there are
you know not enough people who are in
his position because the Democratic
party has drifted so far to the left
they only field extremist candidates
yeah and he's one of those people who
will say whatever he truly believes
which is very dangerous for them I mean
they really do need like you said people
to fall in line he's not that he's a
kind you know the Tulsi gabbard remember
what happened with her like the second
you start speaking your mind you're a
threat to them even if you're in their
party I had a story where I was like
after the debates and I was talking
about during the day you know during the
primaries during the election and I was
like talking to a friend of mine who
just really really hates Donald Trump
really hates Donald Trump and I was like
oh yeah I really like the stuff that
Tulsi gabbard was saying is like Donald
Trump is an existential threat to
America I'm like that what that has
nothing to do with what the hell we're
talking about right now because they'd
already cast her off as somebody who is
a Fringe candidate with these crazy
beliefs and he just kind of lumps all
those people in together whether
Democrat Republican if they don't fall
in line for what at that time would have
been you know your uh your standard
Democrat policies which have gone even
further left since then
um it's crazy
yeah I always I always talk about how
there's new normals created all the time
and so you look every every two to three
years now it used to be the concept of
like a new normal would probably take
decades for them to happen and now you
look on key issues that people used to
vote on they're just becoming more
extreme about those issues to the point
where we're so polarized that there's no
form of rationale anymore in it where
like if I would have told you you know
five ten years ago we're going to put
biological males in prison with women
who have a history of sexually
assaulting women you would say the
entire country would be out protesting
on the street I gotta ask are you do you
face any kind of backlash career-wise
for bringing these subjects up
absolutely well I mean what's that been
like some of them some of them I don't
even know if I should talk about uh from
a legal perspective I will say this we
used to have a lot of celebrities who
supported our our brand uh especially
after this last erased ad that we did
the one with the transgender athlete uh
beating the woman uh we got a lot of
complaints from people saying you're a
transphobic company you're spreading
hate speech to the celebrities who wear
your watches know that you believe these
things and then all of a sudden I
started getting some emails from people
that represent these celebrities wow
threatening do you answer back I'm a
pro-woman company like I I think women
are great and they should compete in
sports you know like the so the to the
people who send the emails I actually
invite them on uh our company podcast to
talk to us and they never accept they
just tell me to go kill myself wow to
the to the legal aspect of things I do
my best to avoid a lawsuit because like
the Womanhood bracelet that we were
selling uh we're going to donate a
percentage of that to Charities that
support the things that we believe in it
becomes very hard if I'm having to fight
legal battles and that's kind of how
they win they try and destroy you in
that way so I'm just sticking to my guns
I play nice where I have to play nice
and when I believe that it's time to
fight back I do but I want to fight back
with a cultural change and I do that
through these videos because we had I'll
be honest with you during this last
video we put out I got a lot of people
who are who even have trans kids saying
the current message for the lgbtq
community is hurting my child people are
starting to hate my child because it's
coming becoming too extreme yeah well we
had a you know front of the show Dale
turn around the other day talking about
you know he's a gay married man and he
was saying the activists are making it
hard and embarrassing for him he was
saying that his husband said you know it
used to be 10 years ago you just mind
your own business and people leave you
alone but now what's going on they're
actually embarrassed to mention that
they're they're getting married
that's that that's what the activists
have made they've pushed it to the
extreme it's like a weird shift where
all they were fighting for originally it
was the right to live their lives the
way they wanted and now the movements
become so extreme that it's forcing
everyone else to kind of celebrate and
be involved and accept everything to the
point where it's damaging them and it's
damaging the way they want it to live
their lives and I don't know how many of
them are aware of just how much damage
it's caused because I used to be in full
transparency a person who would go uh
walk for uh the pride parade you know I
just believed in the notion of anyone
who wants to be married should be able
to be married and over the years because
of how extreme it's going I'm like I
won't support a group that is twerking
in front of kids in you know thongs it
just started to gross me out I'm like
this is not appropriate and then I'm
culture transphobic or homophobic for
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time